art
is not mere entertainment alongside
philosophy and religion it is humanity's
chief source of consolation it is what
we should turn to
in our very worst moments here are
seven of the most calming works of art
ever produced
we are very poor at retaining
perspective
but art can help us by carrying us out
of present circumstances
and reframing events against a more
imposing
or vast backdrop this is the move being
made by the japanese photographer
hiroshi sugimoto through his gigantic
empty photographs of the atlantic ocean
in a variety of moods what is most
notable in these sublime scenes
is that humanity is nowhere in the frame
we're afforded a glimpse of what the
planet look like before the first
creatures emerge from the seas
viewed against such an immemorial scene
the precise discontents of our times
matter ever so slightly less we can
regain composure
not by being made to feel more important
but by being reminded of the minuscule
and momentary nature of everyone
and everything
in ansel adams's photograph a row of
aspens have been surprised by the
photographer's light
and stand out as strands of silver
against the blackness of night
the mood is sombre but elegant there is
a consoling message
within the art that can appease our raw
grief
and anxiety about our mortality and the
fleetingness of time
the image invites us to see ourselves as
part of the mesmerizing spectacle
of nature nature's rules apply to us
as much as they do to the trees of the
forest
it's not personal leaves always wither
and fall
autumn necessarily follows from spring
and summer
the photograph is a reframing device it
invites us to think of our own deaths
as having a natural order that has
nothing to do with individual
justice the photograph tries to take the
personal
sting out of what is happening to us
in the 17th century the dutch developed
a tradition of painting that depicted
ships in violent storms
these works which hung in private homes
and in municipal buildings around the
dutch republic
had an explicitly therapeutic purpose to
them
they were delivering a moral to their
viewers who lived in a nation critically
dependent on maritime trade
a message about confidence in seafaring
and life more broadly
the site of a tall sailing ship being
tossed to a 20 degree
angle in a rough sea looks to an
inexperienced person
like a catastrophe but there are many
situations that look and feel much more
dangerous
than they really are especially when the
crew is prepared
and the ship internally sound
backhoison's warships in a heavy storm
looks chaotic in the extreme how could
the people in this picture possibly
survive
but the ships were well designed for
just such situations
their hulls had been minutely adapted
through long experience
to withstand the tempests of the
northern oceans
backhoes and wanted us to feel proud of
humanity's resilience
in the face of apparently dreadful
challenges
his painting enthuses us with the
message that we can all
cope far better than we think what
appears immensely threatening
maybe highly survivable
the highest selling postcard of art in
france is
poppies by claude monet sophisticated
people
could be tempted to scorn they might be
afraid that such enthusiasm might be
evidence of a failure to acknowledge the
awful dimensions of the world but there
is another way to interpret
a taste for pretty things that it
doesn't arise from an
unfamiliarity with suffering but from an
all-too-close
and pervasive involvement with it from
which we are impelled occasionally
to seek relief if we're not to fall into
despair
so far from naivety it is precisely the
background of
suffering that lends such beauty and
dignity
to this work of art claude monet hasn't
just made
a pretty picture he has bottled hope
casper david friedrich shows us a
striking jagged rock formation
a spare stretch of coast the bright
horizon
far away clouds and a pale sky
all carefully designed to induce us into
a mood
the picture does not refer directly to
the stresses of our day-to-day lives
but its function is to give us access to
a state of mind
in which we are acutely conscious of the
largeness of
time and space the work is somber but
not despairing
and in that condition of mind we are
left as so often with works of art
better equipped to deal with the intense
intractable
and particular griefs that lie before us
the japanese have an artistic tradition
known as kinsugi
where in the broken pieces of an
accidentally smashed pot
a carefully picked up reassembled and
then glued together
with lacquer inflected with a luxuriant
gold powder
to create a beautiful ode to the art
of repair in kinsuki there's no attempt
to disguise damage
the point is to render fault lines
obvious and elegant
the precious veins of gold are there to
emphasize that things falling apart
isn't unexpected or panic inducing it
creates an opportunity
for us to mend and mend redemptively
fernando pessoa is a beautifully dark
monumental work by richard sarah
named after a portuguese poet with a
turn for lamentation
the work does not tell us to cheer up or
point us in a brighter direction
what people often do when we tell them
our troubles the large scale and
monumental character
of this intensely somber sculpture
implicitly declares the normality
and universality of difficulty it is
confident that we will recognize the
legitimate place
of solemn emotions in an ordinary life
rather than leaving us alone with our
darker moods the work proclaims them as
central features
of life in its stark gravity
richard serra's fernando pessoa creates
a dignified home
for sorrow too many books have been
written
trying to explain what art might be for
in moments of great crisis the answer
becomes
only too obvious art is there
to help keep us alive
our book what is culture for helps us
find compassion hope and perspective in
the arts
you